2020火速田席
除完後面還有大的
當天一早就配了97萬五給我了
我們跟骨魚不一樣
一早就賣給骨魚的
分我的位員
大貨給他
真正可以吃到大塊肉的股票
就等老闆來解答
大家知道我很擅長後面
當天除選席喔
還原當天有沒有守住五六軍線
其實他反而是順勢在推動的
所以我剛剛看的老王
我真的比他還短
他還短天而已
有沒有
年紀大短一點是正常的
今天的氣氛
有點臨重
詭異
有點尷尬
對
你們知道有一種就是那種
就突然說要去給我的女朋友
然後送禮物對不對
結果看到
然後門一打開
欸!
這樣
就是你知道有
你是看到我站著
還是看到我躺著
有一次漂亮的雀飛回來
看到你躺著
但是是站著的模樣
很會接
就要黃標了
有一種揪戰雀草感
你是熊揪揪還是胖揪揪
都有
有一隻漂亮的喜鹊飛回來
就看到有一隻揪在這邊
很揪心耶
今天這個揪有準備禮物
有準備禮物
太感人了
給老王
短小金干 后发先制
对 谢谢小哥
但是这个祝贺短小金干这四个字
我们有待商劝
尤其是跟您比
我跟我比吗
你有特短吗
特短
没有 因为那个年纪比较
操作时间特别短
对 年纪比较大也会短一点
为什么
年纪比较大不会短
比较快而已
没有 因为年纪大比较怕风险
短小金干
然後後發先制
這跟我今天要帶來主題一樣
大家知道我很擅長後面
我也以為是小哥擅長
後面給你
我要用前面就好
我們是說股票
你今天要教大家賺前面那一段
我教大家賺後面那一段
不然如果我們再講下去
下次可能看不到這一節目
電視可能不能播了
我們今天理財達人秀
有沒有覺得有春馬花花的感覺
因为有人回娘家
刚回娘家的时候有点震撼
因为里面坐着他的好朋友
也是他们职场上叫做什么呢
有余亮情节吗
据说是没有啦
因为他们两个人呢
在他们的领域都是领先族群
回头看都看不到别人
因为别人都看不到他们的车尾灯
一个呢
是我们普惠头顾的老王
也是网红飞机师老王
一个当然就是我们常来的全镇小哥
哇 两大天王在这边
今天要来教大家什么呢
教大家最想听的就是除全席
应该很多人会想说
除全席还能讲什么啊
除全席还有很多
你不知道的可以学哦
尤其现在很多股票
不是开始已经陆续在除了吗
除完如果你没有跟上的时候
不要忘记后面还有大的
玩大的好不好
所以老王
既然今天你难得回来
玩后面又要玩大的
这一集一定要好好看
因為你沒看到最後
你就會錯過這種
什麼叫玩後面玩大的
對 好
所以我要認真
我先把這個花
謝謝小哥送我這個花
這個
你看一打開門
看到一支啾在我的雀巢
然後還
而且站得很滿
還把花準備好了
站得很滿有沒有
站得很滿
所以我們兩個
怎麼會有餘量情節
我們兩個光size就不一樣了
會有餘量情節
要也是要找個size一樣的
對不對
所以你們兩個不同的市場
喜歡胖啾就喜歡他
你現在有點誤會到我們各自的粉絲
沒有啦 我們兩個感情很好
對 看得出來啦
因為兩位呢
在所謂的投資市場中
真的是領先族群
而且在網路上幾乎無負評
一面倒 真神人就兩位
因為我們兩個有個重點
對 清流
清流
我們兩個自己下有談過很多
達仁秀也是清流節目
對 沒錯 沒錯
對 我們不出貨的
所以今天老王來教我們
其實除全息現在很多陸續在除啦
可是除了之後
其实有人来不及参与前面
他后面有很多可以参与的
好 我们来看一下
尤其今年行情非常特别
怎么说呢
今年有很多一日就填席的
2020火速填席
今年已经除息的股票
现在110档
那里面一日填席的有13档
所以将近有12%的几率
你会买到一日填席
可是赵华必须说
我们的制作人于晨
做了这张表
有陷阱
怎么说呢
台积电是大公司
那它果然是一日填息
但是它是既配
所以2.5块当然马上就填了
可是说实话下面有很多
不是高价股
就是超低价股
配一滴滴的
配这个0.38的也来讲
0.2的也来讲
这种一日填息也是应该
看起来配20块的
可是因为股价太贵了
所以殖利率其实很差
一%而已
他就这样动一下
小哥敲进去几张
就有了 就天氣了
老王喊一下馬上好不好
馬上漲停了
所以重頭戲還沒有出來
基優股或者是說真正可以吃到大塊肉的股票
就等老王來接答
大家對除選席都有憧憬
可是我要提醒大家
我在這個節目
我們是節目的第一集
沒錯
老王說實話第一集
你知道什麼
我長大之後就不參加除選席了
為什麼
因為你看這個情況
除選席前面急拉一波
然後到除選席之後
就開始貼息了
這完全沒有填息
沒有填息不打緊
可能還會再往下走跌
那我問你
如果你是一些大股東
或者說有錢的買的
比較多 張數比較多一點的
你不但貼息 你還要怎樣
繳稅
那你的麻煩就很大了
所以你等一下被扒兩成皮
那再來 如果你是空手的
你不要在這個地方去買
你等一下跌下來
從這一天之後的每一天
都比這個還低
代表是我閉著眼睛買
我都可以買到比你除選期前去買的點位還低
所以我的成本是不是比你好
對 可是如果買得低的話
我當然希望它後來還是要漲上去
要是它一路貼下去
那就是接下來我們要觀察重點
我們先給大家一個提醒
就是說等除選期後再來買
有一些方法讓我覺得會比較OK
那我怎麼知道哪一天要買
你看它跌跌跌
像剛剛你舉的例子跌了四天
要是我第一天貼席就去買
我就被套牢了
你講這是很多的問題嘛
所以你來看一下除選期之後
你要先观察
有没有大涨
我们用这个用很快讲过去
我等一下会有实力
第二个呢
除选席后的一周呢
一周就是除选席
刚除选席那一周
请你切换到还原的日K线图
OK吗
全席还原回去
如果你连还原
或什么叫做非还原
你都不知道
不要玩
没关系
那个私讯造华
我会回你
个人账号知不知道
你造华
好 我会回答你
然后再来第三个
还原日K线
守住5日跟20日线
这重点
就我們切換到還原日K線之後
我們要注意它還有沒有守住5日跟20日
最後我們來看守住就容易在漲
跌破就容易漲
請你不要再隨便抄底了
可是5日20日是一個長短期不同的均線
所以兩個都要守住嗎
因為我跟你講
因為我是做比較短線的人
所以我個人都看短線
但是因為我們來上節目
很多人喜歡參加雛選席
是比較想要撥斷寫一點的
所以我算是買蔥送青菜的概念
我今天講我的短線
也順便打一些撥斷操作的原則
告訴大家
我覺得你現在很人性化
活來的
因為你知道我們電視觀眾
有時候手腳真的沒那麼快
有時候被套住需要點安慰
我們今天實在不能閒聊
因為各位觀眾你看
我們今天準備
我們要再十幾分鐘講完
所以我們講話速度會快一點
還是慢慢講
回娘家嘛慢慢講
所以你千萬真的不能去上廁所
你去上廁所
這個一下子講完了
台塑
我們講一個台塑
我們先講去年的經驗
除全息前是不是往上急功
感覺很棒啊
然後股價也都一路往上對不對
從這裡底部到這裡漲很多
從現途看很開心
除選習了
這個前置就是除選習的字號
看起來很醜
因為它跳下去
股息配了很多嘛
配好幾塊
所以很醜
這樣的情況下
如果你單純用形態學說
這個跳空嘛
很醜啊
跌破所有均線啊
那我應該賣掉
錯 不應該
因為你第一個禮拜
如果它這個錢
不像那些都除比較少
如果它錢比較多一點
全部都會有出現跳空
很大的跳空
而且會跌破所有均線
這時候請你怎樣
按照剛才我們那個小法點
請你用還原的日K線
你把它還出來
這是還原全值的
就還原全值的
我們先看日K線
先看日K線
就日K線來就會存現這個圖
就是很標準
一出旋期是出旋期之後
就會跌破五日
跌破月均線
二十日跟五日都跌破了
按照我們以前教的
完了弱勢股
跌破月均線
這個變三生無奈
要砍對不對
可是出旋期的時候
不能這樣玩
出旋期的時候你要看還原的日K線畢竟你還是有拿到席是嘛所以你你要還原過去但是這個期限有保存期限的喔只能看一個禮拜喔為什麼因為我們寬限它這個缺口
一個禮拜真的要給我補掉
盡量
補個交易日
如果你補不上去喔
那可能你後面有一點問題喔
我們等一下都會持續來做範例的探討
好 那所以你看
這已經是還原日K線喔
結果它在還原的當天喔
還往下殺喔
而且是殺破什麼
五日跟月均線
那不就不行了
那你可能覺得是第一...
不行這個字有點敏感啦
我們通常講股價就轉落啦
轉落
那如果你看這邊
欸!第二天還是在轉落
趙華已經跌破了5日
又跌破了10日
標準的弱勢股了
已經給你看還原了喔
那這種股票你要不要報
不要
不能報嘛
所以你看喔
經過我們說一個禮拜嘛對不對
給它一個禮拜
一個禮拜都沒站回去喔
那顯然就是一個標準的弱勢股了
就一個禮拜都站不起來
對 考驗日特價站不起來嘛
那這時候呢
你知道後來發生什麼事
各位觀眾
哇
後來股價就真的一路跌
那你知道
我說一個禮拜
一個禮拜內是看還原
那一個禮拜後
像在一個禮拜之後
你是不是就看正常的K線
正常K線回來看
它還是在五日之下
它還是在月均線之下
那代表它是什麼
標準的弱勢股嗎
真的不能碰
這樣的話
即使你是除選期前去買的
還有除選期後去買的
你都沒有開心
完全沒開心
那你空手根本去買
有提醒大家
如果是空手想要介入的話
都一定要等月均線
空手要介入
记好我这叫比据
一定要跃均线
如果你这边你都知道
它是落实股了
上赵华你就很聪明了
你绝对不会去碰这张股票
因为它缺口一直没补
所以我们过来看
后来台数发生什么事
我们刚才看到位置在这
除旋鞋位置在这
你等一点在这
最后摔到剩下90块
90块没摔完
因为后来又发生原油负值
原油期负负值
负油价的问题
更崩嘛
所以我只是截图
只截到这里
所以完全标准的贴席
到现在还在贴
所以這種股票當然你就要避開
那你說老王 照你這樣講的話
不就是剛才台塑在除選席前有大漲
這種股票不能碰 是這樣道理嗎
聽起來好像是
因為你的第一條有看他是否大漲
這樣有點一竿子打翻一傳人
那我們就要仔細看 再來看一個
重點在這裡 來 一樣 宏傑克
這除選席這個mark在這裡
當天除選席
他在除選席之前先大漲一波
這漲很大耶
你剛才台塑說不能買嘛
這種除選席大漲能不能買
我跟你講喔
這個你知道認真聽下去
這個關鍵在什麼
關鍵在台塑
它不是當初的主流
你要去分辨這個族群
這個個股是不是主流
有沒有題材對不對
去年長最萌是什麼
就是那個5G的應用嘛
5G概念古
深化家嘛
那宏傑克就是嘛
他長這一段嘛
所以他是主流
深化家是主流
這種遇到大漲的時候
其實他反而是順勢在推動的
這種反而可以參加儲權席
所以你先把大漲的定義先分開來囉
如果你不是主流
你大漲那你要小心
那可能是不知道為什麼
然後就有人去想要他的股息
可能適得其犯
但是如果你是主流
來 再看這張
我們再給他還原K
我們剛才是在當時日K
如果還原K的話
你可以發現
在這個地方
還原當天
有沒有守住五日均線
有耶 好強耶
五日均線更遠嘛
它是標準強勢股
那我空手可不可以去買
當然可以啊
那如果我不是空手
我本來就持有的
那我怕被套嘛
我怕賠了價差
可是我現在看
我剛出拳完
馬上還守住喔
我可不可以繼續報
可以喔
你就可以期待他填席
關鍵在這兒它是主流
包括它還原日K也首數五日
我們再看下一張
然後在哪
各位觀眾我看那位置在哪
剛才位置在這
然後就移入砸下去了
所以看短線的五日均線是不是賺錢了
有嘛對不對
所以是不是可以說
像現在大家在流行講落後補掌
這種反而不太適合參加出水型
反而不太適合
我覺得是強格很強的
神技類股
可是這些類股你還是要看有沒有基本面
很多這些類股根本沒有配息
這根本就配不出來嘛
那你在看我們剛才說
月均線是看波段的嘛
就是說你喜歡超過五日均線的人
你從這裡除選期當天
然後就買進去超超超超到這裡
是不是跌破五日均線
你就做出場了嘛
那符合老王最喜歡做很短的嘛
就這麼短嘛
我想做長一點的可不可以
可以啊
來一樣看這一張
那我們剛才是
這是還原日K
因為我說一個禮拜之後
一個禮拜之後要回到看
我們只能給他五個交易日的機會
就要看日K
正常日K
一樣把月均線拿出來看
那除選期的位置在這
然後你看它是不是短線在這邊就出場了嘛
可是長線呢 越前線沒破啊
那你就一路抱抱抱抱抱抱
哇 是不是又往上一路漲到這邊70幾塊
這邊灌破才賣掉
那是不是長短接矣嘛
那你要注意喔 主流族群不會只有一檔個股
生化家是主流嘛
那我們大家知道洪捷克
他用另外一檔是什麼 龍頭 穩帽
穩帽也是生化家嘛 對不對
同一個族群用同樣的玩法
那所以你發現這個族群有某一檔個股
已經填尖洗了 你要用你的腦袋思考
那個腦袋思考
另外一檔也有可能跟上
我們比如說看五帽
五帽的除選期在這個地方
他在除選期前是不是也是大漲
可是他是主流
主流我們就認為他應該要大漲
這種大漲就沒關係
好 那你這邊
我們看一下還原全息
這是還原日K線
他有沒有守住五日均線
有
有嘛 還原的當天就守住了
基本上是強勢股
那我空手可不可以去買
當然可以啊
那我們再看一下
這裡是還原日K
他在這邊去買進之後
就一路漲漲漲到這裡來
那你如果觀察五日均線
這邊都守住啊
到這邊才跌破嘛
所以五月軍線還是可以賺這麼一大段
所以你說主流雛群
其實這樣我們一個定論
參加雛權席好像是對的
可是主流族群
是不是每一年都是同樣主流
這就不一定了
今年生外價就比較弱了
所以你要看當年的主流
比如說今年主流就是生機育股
對 但是這樣的話
如果今年這個族群裡面
有好幾檔要輪流雛權席
我是不是就可以輪流做它
你怎麼那麼聰明啊
沒錯 因為回來看日K線
我們說一個禮拜過後就看日K線
那長線就看月均線嘛
所以不只是坐短喔
坐長也可以喔
所以大家搞清楚這個觀念嗎
因為好 我再講喔
台股不會只有一個主流
今年也許生技
結果接下來可能要換到其他主流
也有可能
對 老玩爸先透露接下來要換到誰
因為你講過生技
我們很多這種有道行的人
其實不太敢碰
不太敢碰對不對
那我們今天主要是舉例
我先把例子舉完
因為一個市場不會只有一個主流
去年還長一個主流
不出了生化家小哥應該也知道
長這個嘛 剪刀腳的嘛
剪刀腳
就是這個 你也一定知道嘛
主持這麼簡單
就是蘋果併跟他的鍵盤設計嘛
晶圓就是受惠的嘛
結果你看他在除選席前喔
長了兩倍囉
那如果按照我們技術分析
一般的形態
這不叫N字型上檔嘛
等幅測距就這一段拿來
長好了 長好檔滿了
找完了
不會再長了
除選席就是高點要你命
這種是錯誤的
為什麼 因為老王說
主流族群的除選席是可以參加的
所以你來看
主流就是主流
我們一樣買
第一天要看還原日K嘛
除選鞋當天有沒有守住五日軍線
有嘛
所以我空手手養的
或本來就我去參加的
可不可以耐心抱著
of course
英文聽得懂
我不會問小哥
因為小哥一定聽得懂的
他常出國玩
小哥熊中好好
對啊
所以回過來看
剛才除選鞋位置在這
對
後面有沒有標一大段
守住五日軍線又往上
這個不是稍微跌破五日軍線了嗎
那你就是老王
說實話沒看清楚
我們有教大家
如果避免被洗掉
自己回去爬文
爬YouTube啦
你替貴節目增加流量
我們會在下面放連結
放連結 或者資訊卡
你看他還是漲上來
真正跌步在這個地方
所以我剛才這樣的結論
再提醒大家一次
如果是主流出群
但請注意是當下主流
你不要說生技今年很強
可是他後來崩盤的時候
那不是主流
就是當下最熱門的主流
在除群席
我覺得一定是OK的
好 沒關係
等一下我們請老王
再幫我們偷偷透露
今年還有哪些主流
但剛剛老王有講
如果是主流的話
他一路長上去
其實不只玩後面啦
你前面也玩
抱住玩後面都可以
但今天小哥來
小哥呢
他現在也很主流
他呢
比現在有一個很有名的人物
叫做雞排妹
更加厲害
因為今年為什麼說
要比雞排妹厲害
今年最厲害的叫散戶
對
因為散戶呢
比外資還強
我昨天
這個跟雞排妹一樣
也PO一個IG
你也PO一個IG啊
對 我也有IG啊
這麼潮喔
是啊
那鸡排妹是在上的周五
她就说
她买翼龙今天涨停
遇到这种好运降临
她很有爱心
把股票获利的三成捐出
我跟她一样我也买翼龙
你也买翼龙
你看吧
今年都在跟
跟她吗
跟一些股票少人
不是
因为翼龙在那天除息
我是在除息前一天晚而已
我年纪小
所以我专门玩除全席
这是当天除全席的对帐账
当天我买了一龙棋
买了75口
账面赔444000
好不吉利
怎么赔那么多
怎么那么殊
还444000
这个不要害怕
主要是因为我领到了古希拉
当天一早他就发了他发了75口因為一口是兩張是一張配6500
所以他當天一早就配了97萬5給我了
我們所謂買現股最怕賺了股息賠了價差
可是小哥用各股期
所以他賠了小小的價差卻賺了大大的股力
對 沒錯
那一開盤我們就賣掉了
一開盤就賣掉也太短吧
所以我剛剛看的老王
我真的比他還短
老王是開玩的不買
對
你還玩五天
我才玩兩天而已
小樂
年紀大短一點是正比
是快
這個是成正比
快 你不要一直猜
我們講的是股票好不好
這是財經台
你這樣講好像要來賣藥了
對
但是現在重點是老王
至少教我們看五個交易日
小哥就看除全息
當天來決定我要怎麼做對不對
對
我們非常短
當天開高就賣掉了
因為我們跟古魚不一樣
原來魚樣群結找到
魚嘛 他是魚嘛
古魚他說玩後面風火輪嘛
對 他要一直連續填心
風火輪嘛 對不對
我們是一早就賣給古魚的
風火輪會員嘛
到貨給他
還好他們喜歡玩後面
對 他們可以抱很久
每個人都跟我們一樣
開盤賣壓很大
對
那你看 還好後面就跌下來
還好很多人是不擅長一開盤就賣的
我們是一開盤就要賣
這是紀律啊
那奇交所呢
在這個契約上面呢
他就會寫 像這個義龍
配發6.5塊股票鼓勵
現金鼓勵
然後呢 他就會調整權益數
調整權益數就是直接把股票鼓勵
現金鼓勵就拿給你了
對 每一口買方呢
權益數加相加1萬3
直接給
或啰嗦
当天就发
对
我们买现股不是这样
现股要等半个月
有入障日
现金股要等比较久
对啊
那时候股票都不知道去哪里了
没错
好 那我们还是要再复习一下
初期一日比较容易涨的
对
其实你要看最近主力有没有买
对 因为小哥你现在做的就是
除息当天开高就把它卖掉
对 我们可能是前一天买
或前前一天买
对
所以我们可能是买一天
或买两天
好
顶多买三天
我刚刚看到这五天好长
老王也被夸长
我也是有长处的
没有人说过长
很少有人叫我长
有些时候人家都会说得特别长
但是就是
什么时候
不是在白天的时候
我们要大标普的时候
沿着五日局线喷出的时候
光头大红棒这样子
好
所以前两天或顶多前三天买
然后除夕当天开高立刻走人
立刻走了
好
那第一个要找这个主力再买
第二个除去当天历史开高居高
这边有讲
就是主力的五日筹码集中度
要大于5%的
这个很多软体可以去查一下
有这样的一个指标
没错
那第三呢
现金值率大于5%
这个不是古鱼的
对啊
常用的吗
考一下造化
你猜看看
为什么要找现金值率比较高的
现金值率比较高的
因为他发的现金多
代表他去年是有获利的工资
还有因为现金值率高
所以他今天一开盘
的价格看起来会蛮低的
蒸发了比较多一点
举例来说100块配5块
当天一开盘剩95块
95元
配8块剩92块
那假如有些人呢
有些人他每天一早出门
他就挂尾挂单
昨天100嘛
那今天我挂98
买看看好了
就当天就被他买到了
就不小心成交了
因为这种人还蛮多的
所以很多现金值率高的股票
当天容易开高
过名就里的买单就买了
对 我们就吃吃这些人的豆腐就好了
像易龙店它现金值率都不错
但是你这边有讲到常态性开高
常态性开高
不是一次两次
你看之前的现金值率
有6% 9% 5%
今年是5%
剛剛好符合你的條件
沒錯
然後它歷年來
開高機率100%
100%
雞排妹肯定知道些什麼
那我們是在前一天
挑的時間點不錯
那我們講一下
我當天的買點在哪邊
因為前一天它有回檔一些
隔天又開低
開低就去買
所以其實在這一天
你開低買的
隔天你賣掉
有的當天
他就临到股息了
所以小哥反而是
还是会看一下
他有下修
下修的反而你觉得比较容易
而且他又是过去开高几率100%的
没错
因为这几天台股九连红
你知道吗
九连红
要做多的时候都觉得毛毛的
好不容易回档
一龙天要除息赶快进场
当天你看一下
有个分点在这边大卖
为什么呢
这大卖就是大股东
大股东自己大卖
可是如果大股东大卖不是不好吗
因为大股东他缴的税缴太多了
对 他宁愿卖掉
然后之后再买回来
最近他就买回来
所以小哥的意思是
大股东很容易在参加除去期前
卖投票
所以如果看到这个迹象
先不要觉得这档没有后市
对不对
对 他很容易在除期当天就会开高
好
好 那除期日开高
我们看到这个除期日开高
假如你做得好的话
前一天你有买
隔天卖掉
各位看一下在这边
对
在这边
其实这个没有
这是原来的K线
并没有还原
其实你有可能就赚到6块半了
那假如对小资组而言
他鼓励课税是5%
是
鼓励课税他要课325块
但现在政府的得正
退税8.5%
但是这个只适用于税率是5%的
小资组的
你假如是12%以上
你就要讲
像王董这种应该有40%的
40%
我做工的人啊
我都叫我哈
你做工的人
那我总要参加哦
要参加哦
小资组参加这还蛮不错的
还有退税
你赚6700
对
好
比那个股息领到的
还可以再加上退税的钱
双赚
那我们来看这个历年来
这个高几率开高的除息标准
对 因为这个很重要
因为刚刚讲那些例子
大家会很羡慕
就像我们有时候挑股票
大家说都你们在挑标股啊
我哪知道哪一档会开高
就几率会高的
所以其实有软体可以筛
那我们来看最近的
这个开高机率比较高的
像联发科
联发科这个还没有除
好 联发科还没有除
还没除
历年来有89%开高
可以来试试看
还不错
像台达电也还没有除
这也是好意思
历年来有78%的机率开高
因为这种好公司
就像小哥讲的
其实都会有一堆人
想要开盘去买它
对 而且
拿来当存股嘛
对 重点它有个股期货
交易量又好
所以我们蛮喜欢这种标的
因为像小哥
你就可以用各股期
做到刚刚那样讲的
可能赔一点点加差
可是股期当天就入袋
那如果不擅长做期货的
一样现股可以这样做
合起来赚很多
那最后我们要讲一下
这个去年有一个
历年来开高几率很高的
去年它是百分之百开高
去年开始说百分之百开高
不过去年它就开平盘而已
你知道为什么吗
为什么
因为去年太多人认为
他百分之百开高
太早进场
所以这个东西也会有时候会失效就對了
他会让怎么样
他会让这个太早进场了
他会让这个投资人
这个投资人太早进场
就会让他涨幅提早发生
所以他是除权签
他就可能就开始往上走了
对 没错
好 所以这也要注意
开高几率高的也要留意
可能有人提早布局了
好 那我们来看一下
这个当时的龙刚就这样
因为呢
全正投資人買太多
所以導致它漲幅提早發生
那除息當天就會跌下來
是 好 所以這個反而要留意
如果他在前一天
發現很多人去佈局了
那可能他就不會造成
我建議就不要加除息了
就不要參加了
因為他的百分之百神話
可能就破滅了
太多人玩 我們就玩前面
就是這個意思
太多人搶後面 你就玩前面
沒人搶後面 你就玩後面
對
所以就是人多的地方不要去
可是偏偏我常常看到啊
後面明明就是我的
為什麼要跟我搶
可是我常常看到
後面就站著你們兩個人在那邊
剛才看到那個小哥的
那其實這些
還是可以統整出一個
我剛才前面講的規律
他剛才這個翼龍店對不對
翼龍店其實剛才照我來講
今年這個台股
尤其在九連紅的階段
最強的主群
其實還不是生技股最強的主群是IC設計因為當時有我們的身家電子掛牌嘛高價股我們光IC設計千金股就三四千斤了你知道嗎所以當時那個IC是
益龍
金牌妹為什麼會去買這個益龍
有可能就是因為它看到
是主流嘛
那一樣的道理
所以買這個主流
本來就容易
讓你賺到這個田圈區行前
不然是前面的
還是我的後面的嘛
那再看看龍鋼喔
龍鋼它本來就是鋼鐵股嘛
它
我看它走勢也平平嘛
去年所以你知道它是主流
那本來就有點難嘛
所以像對我們這種
你只要玩後面的
這種就是完全不會去看啦
當然它有可能開高的比例
可是至少我們就會去過濾掉
這個就是它比較不會是主流的條件
那你說聯發科嘛
聯發科它本來也是
就像是熱門股嘛
那如果是大量主流
所以我現在要跟大家講
今年的主流啦
要嘛就是生技股
要嘛就是IC設計
就是IC設計
就這兩個
可是IC設計因為先前漲多
所以稍微再震盪一下
那你可能就是我所謂的
我剛才再次強調
就是你要等當下再衝的時候
那個時候除選席
那個才是要真的主流
比如說生技股
現在就人在除選席的
當然OK 因為生技股現在正強
你不要等到生技股又休息了
然後說我在除選席
那就會有點問題
大家聽得懂這個意思
不過標的真的都沒什麼股息
標的都是夢想
所以你的參加也少
還是看IC設計就很多了
IC設計在第一季的營收
表現非常好
只要他們殖利率比較弱
對 好
講完這個大數
那你意思是說
那基本面好像好的
我要跟大家講
因為有的觀眾會想說
我自己挑股票
我習慣
尤其是那种比较在股票市场
久一点的人都会说
我会参加股票就两种
就是机优股我一定参加
这尤其是我们比较在股海
久一点的人会参加
机优股为什么不参加
稳定
就你刚才说
滚水球这也封火轮
不是我的时候
不在这里
鱼的鱼的
这当然一定要慎选机优股
你都不机优
你怎么会有滚
那这个是股海也比较久
那菜鸟
今年很多菜鸟的路市
散户路市
他们会看到什么
今年一檔股價100塊
除息要發30塊
這種的嚇死你
發很多錢
吹零不可啊
就是要賺股息的啊
因為他們會一直覺得
就是剛進股市的小白兔
會覺得說30塊配給我
那我就是現賺30了
這個觀念當然是非常離譜的
沒有一定的
所以現在王董要來告訴大家
這兩個
攻破你的弱點
第一個
夜外依注
這當然是2018年之前的新聞
盡力配息30塊
一檔股要配30
今日跳空漲泥
一直說他配股配息很多
你會不會因為覺得他配30塊好像很多
我會在這個消息公布的時候
限段3萬一張
去買股票然後再把它賣掉
或者是說我在他除元席線我就參加
反正除完我就一定贏
我告訴你
事情不是說人家
所想的這麼簡單
這土漲的好驚悚
可是他是日K線
正常的日K線
一定跳下來
因為他除了30塊那麼多
可是我剛才教了你不要只看
前一個禮拜不要看日K線
因為你被嚇死
那以後就會賣在地板
你說趕快砍掉
錯
所以這個時候
我們在複習
我們這個時候看什麼
除選席後的一個禮拜
我們都一起看
還原日K線
這個就是還原日K
那我們把這遮起來
還原日K
一除選席在這個地方
就一路漲停
所以你持有的
我有真的去買進去
你是不是可以抱著就好
反正他有讓你賺錢
可是到了後面
大概第四天
第五天
不太妙
跌破五日均線
跌破五日均線代表他怎樣
開始轉落了
你應該要做減碼了
然後空手要小心不要進去了
再跌到月均線這邊也跌破了
代表說它這場股票只有短線的行情
你從還原日K
還原日K已經跌破五日跟月均線了
你是空手這個時候要不要進去買
不行
你要嘛空手就這邊去賺嘛
你有本事去搶到漲停板嘛
那你賣這邊其實還一點點價差
它是異常的配息啦
異常的配息
因為它是業外易住嘛
有些公司或是去年賺很多也會特別多啊
這種特別多的不見得是賣土地
反正就特別多的
跟歷年比起來怪怪的
你要注意啦
不過我現在觀眾已經聰明了啦
他是業外易住30塊
大家都會知道
這種東西沒有辦法
那我來講一個
大家很難避免掉地雷
好
基歐股
很愛犯
基歐股又有問題
基歐股存錢
一定沒什麼問題吧
沒問題啊
保證你問題很多
我跟你講
套住就當存股嘛
對
那你要去存交股魚啊
好來
看評了
我們看漢評的部分
漢評
這個過去31塊
在這邊
漲到40幾塊
30幾塊漲10塊
漲很多了
三層多了
就進入了橫盤震盪
然後想說 這邊你可以看到他除選席
我到底要不要參加
其實漢平這個基本面
看起來沒有什麼問題啊 也沒大漲啊
其實漢平的基本面很好
當時他的基本面 非常大的成長
那我這種基有股
我應該要參加除選席喔
可是你一參加
而且你看這個線席是慢慢整理
之後要往上 它不是什麼大漲過的啊
好 沒關係 我們回過台
一樣從頭交 除選席當天
如果你看日K線 刷下去
因為他除了 賺比較多嘛
所以他配的比較多嘛
那就跌一個缺口,又跌破五日跟越軍線
完了,弱勢股,空方股,掛了
No,No,No,不要這樣思考
不是要看還原日K嗎
所以要看還原嗎
還原第一天好像就不太行了
第一天開高走低就...
還原還是那麼醜
那再給他一點機會
第二天還是...
第二天就連越軍線都跌破了
那不行了
連現在趙華都知道不行了
所以趙華今天學到一個詞叫不行了
不行了,不行了
不行了怎麼辦呢
我們再回過頭來看還原日K
就真的一路崩了耶
就一路崩了,肌肉股耶
成長一路蹦蹦蹦蹦
所以我還是提醒大家
他的業績很好
怎麼好了
我給大家看這個方法
對 因為你剛剛講說
他有業績很大的成長
那什麼業績很大的成長
反而貼息咧
成長就應該要填息啊
那你知道為什麼嗎
對啊 為什麼
因為我們說
股價永遠領先反應什麼
基本面喔
還有內線
這是他最新的
這是他最近的營收
來 你看一下
最近的營收是這樣
都是兩三成在衰退
這是今年的嘛
可是他去年填錢
去年配息的嘛
去年,各位觀眾朋友,你繼續找一下,去年它在這邊,全部都是成長的,40%50%在成長,可是今年是這樣,所以我就告訴大家,一個股票,如果你現在看它業績很好,但它除選期的缺口,怎麼樣都補不起來,那就是後面有貓膩。
我懂你的意思了,它在透露它的業績成長可能出現了問題。
只是我們說基本面是比較慢的
不會那麼早反應嘛
可是懂的人
大股東那些人懂的人
反正像小哥講的
他除選期前
假設我不是說這張股票
我們說是舉例其他股票
他可以再除選期前先賣股票了
可是他不見得要買回來啊
照理說如果大股東很好的話
他可能這張股票
他就買回來嘛
他就漲上來嘛
避稅而已
是 所以跟大家講
有時候基友股
你還是除選期的
當天還是請把他還原日K線來看
我覺得會讓你避開一些風險
其實龍龍交的是一個撇步
就是說他今年業績明明就是一直成長
可是為什麼除完全息之後
它還在貼
一直貼一直貼
就代表它後面的業績
可能跟不上
而不是說
因為它借機很好
一直貼的時候
我越買越便宜
我就每天買
這是錯誤的觀念
好 所以這也是一個觀測
先行指標
謝謝老王又教我們一招
那一樣 趙華要非常感謝
老王今天回娘家
那當然也希望老王
未來能夠常常回娘家
甚至也來加入
我們的精英班行列
老王在那邊
面帶難色
但是沒關係
還是要來謝謝各位網友
就加入精英班的
給了我們非常多的鼓勵
所以趙華 趙麗在節目的後面
都會來跟大家說一聲
謝謝你 好不好
謝謝你對這個佛心節目的支持
這個佛心節目
其實最早最早的來賓
就是老王
老王現在也在做佛心的事業了
那我們來捏一些網友
給我們的鼓勵
這個叫Alan
他說謝謝趙華美女
理財當然就讓我受益良多
感覺每位老師
還有很多寶藏可以挖
會的 努力的鴨炸好不好
包括像小哥
我們哪一天如果看到小哥瘦了20公斤
你就知道趙華你把它炸乾了
然後這個Shine好像來過很多次
他說謝謝你們很佛心的價錢
然後Alice說
趙華的主持功力真的很好
不曉得老王可不肯定
因為老王現在比較少來
當然
他說完全不冷場
而且都問到精髓
讚讚讚
是的
我一定會把老王的精髓
小哥的精髓都挑出來
好
那今天非常謝謝
老王 回娘家
还有我们的全镇小哥
再一次来教大家除全席的技巧
老王是告诉你
有一些机率要看什么
还原日K线看五天
你才能决定
你要不要再除席后去买
有的买了之后
还有很大的破断可以做
但是反过来
有的一除其实就已经完蛋了
他也告诉你
根本就不要在他除席后去捡
那小哥更狠了
小哥告诉你
当天开高立刻卖掉
除全席前一两天去布局
当天开高马上卖掉
老王還加碼告訴你喔
他說有些股票看起來是成長股
可是除完全息後一直貼息
就偷偷的在暗示
他今年的業績成長後面可能不如預期
是不是學到很多呢
那今天的理財達人秀
謝謝大家參與
我們下次再見囉
拜拜
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive